hi I'm Erik Bosse and stranger things is
a new trailer for its third season on
Netflix and boy has the production
budget gone up almost as high as the
shorts on the fellas in the summer of 85
it's a scorcher I'm gonna break down
this trailer shot-by-shot for all the
details you might have missed and all
the various 80s movies that are being
referenced cuz this is stranger thing
since more than warning against my
speculations that be to write rules your
life let's get started okay the trailer
opens on this summer carnival hosted by
Hawkins new mayor Mayor Cline played by
Cary Elwes of the Princess Bride the
previous trailer showed shots of Hawkins
protesting save Downton so maybe mayor
Klein's big new development the star
court mall is doing what a lot of malls
did in the 80s well beyond sheepishly
waving at her crushes outside Spencer's
gifts or if your girl getting your ears
pierced at Claire's shudder a lot of
American towns small businesses whereas
now malls are closing because of Amazon
always a bigger fish and maybe this
carnival is to raise money for those
struggling businesses and really for
mayor Klein to say face ahead of
re-election next there's Dustin his
mother Steve Harrington Lucas's sister
Erica and new character Rose who works
with Steve and ice cream a-hole a shop
in the mall these four show up together
a few times in this trailer I feel like
they're a bit of a side group the other
group appears to be Mike Wheeler will
buyers max Lucas Lucas looks to be
wearing that Daniel son Karate Kid
inspired outfit and 11 as 11 visits the
upside down notice the nosebleed there
to investigate perhaps this new
supernatural threat that isn't new at
all this is the mind flayer who's
sticking around from last season we hear
this disembodied voice that seems to be
coming from the mind player itself but
this is apparently the voice of Jake
Busey who is playing a character in this
season character credited by the name
Bruce and Bruce could be a nod to the
name that the production of Jaws gave to
its problematic shark robot a
problematic because it kept breaking
down not because it was like racist 11
can be seen in the upside down
equivalent of this place now this is the
Aaron Bourne Steel Works Factory which
actually shows up later in this trailer
now it's covered in this red fog a
funnel cloud
evoking the mind flayers presents from
lat
season but yes here he is still a threat
still very much part of their world
Munna I closed the gate
what if he never left
what a free [ __ ] tonight here with us
okay in this section 11 recalls her
seeming defeat over the mind flayer at
the end of season 2 when she used her
telepathic / telekinetic powers to seal
the portal shut the Dark Phoenix style
finale that we should have gotten dark
Phoenix but apparently that victory was
a false victory then there's a shot of
Mama Steve Dustin Erica and Rose beside
this antenna that Dustin has set up this
could be a way for the kids to tap into
the communication waves of the mine
flare or boosts eleven signal into the
upside down then there are goosebumps
forming on the back of wills neck as he
watches this movie and senses that
something is wrong it's kind of hard to
tell which movie he's watching from this
shot though what is the summer of 1985
and these folks seemed to be loved in
this movie so I'm guessing it could be a
crowd-pleaser like Back to the Future
where the Goonies through The Breakfast
Club weird science something else this
show is already stolen its characters
aesthetics and plot points from next
clip
you'd want to attach himself to someone
again
[Music]
a new host okay here rats
swarm into that steel factory that 11
visited in the upside down which might
be the Gateway point for the mind flayer
Billy that season two smoke show appears
to now be a new host for the mind flayer
there's a quick shot of the mind player
flashing over Billy who appears to be in
some kind of trance
so after barb in season one Bob in
season two
Billy would be the third bee who falls
victim to the upside down threat now
this voice keeps referring to himself as
plural saying we and us suggesting that
he might operate as some kind of hive
mind maybe possessing an army of human
hosts it's kind of like an invasion of
the body snatchers kind of thing but
then judging from some other shots in
season 3 footage
maybe he's also turning people into
inhuman Cronenberg e monsters perhaps
actually that might be what happens to
these rats one of the episodes in the
season is called mole rats maybe they're
gonna be turned into nasty otherworldly
mutant forms that invade the town of
Hawkins they mentioned that mind flayer
is building something maybe that thing
is a new world with all earth life-forms
mutated into interdimensional monstrous
forms of themselves and kind of re
terror forms it for himself
that's what I would do moving on
[Music]
no matter what happens we have to stop
them
together
here people in protective suits approach
a Collider type particle beam device as
it wrecks the lab with energy blasts
actually evokes that blinding portal
imagery of poltergeists I'm guessing
this is some part of the Hawkins energy
lab that we've seen in previous seasons
but I'm thinking that season 3 might
reveal that the new star Court mall has
been built on top of the old lab site
kind of like cover up but the
underground infrastructure in tunnels of
that lab have been left intact so the
poltergeist parallel might not be
incidental because in that movie the
housing development was built atop an
old burial ground to cover up the truth
that they didn't move the bodies you son
of a [ __ ] y'all only moved an stones
then there's a shot of this new
character beside a sheriff truck but
this guy probably ain't a cop notice
he's wearing black gloves so I think he
came upon this truck abandoned because
he's tracking someone down months ago
there were rumors that a Russian
character was being cast so maybe this
dude is the Soviet spy snooping around
tokens hoping to report back to
motherland ways to weaponize his
supernatural force then there are shots
of everyone gearing up with weapons
Nancy with the shotgun Jonathan with the
axe Lukas with the slingshot from season
one now I get it happened in the first
time but why does it keep falling to
these children is the only lines of
defense against interdimensional
existential threats like why does anyone
still live in Hawkins I guess I would
keep asking these kind of questions we
just won't have a stranger things so
let's move on
we are going to end you where you're
going to end your Frost then we are
going to end every
in this section it looks as though Billy
has brought a bound victim to this
monster perhaps for feeding or hasn't
got a human sacrifice and we get a
little glimpse at this creature and it
looks nasty now I mentioned before the
practical body horror of directors like
David Cronenberg but I also think john
carpenter's work in the thing could be a
major design influence here just as it
was for the demo Gorgon in season 1 I'm
thinking this victim could be Nancy
since we later see her facing this
monster in the trailer though it could
also be Heather the lifeguard a new
character who works with Billy and one
of these eight episodes is called the
case of the missing lifeguard and we
hear this voice saying we are going to
end you your friends everyone over shots
of will Michael Evan and Lucas and then
Julie spires hopper and the reporter
character from last season Marie Baumann
all joining this chaos in the mall and
then fireworks over the carnival with
mr. and mrs. wheeler with Nancy and
Mike's little sister Holly her eyes
watch the fireworks but then they
glanced down because the next shot shows
the trees being wrestled as something
big plows through them a nod to the
famous Raptor shot in the lost world on
to the next clip
kids are in danger they need to invest
I can fight better than any of us and
each estate
okay here mayor Cline stumps at the
carnival his character might be a nod to
the mayor from Jaws who also insisted on
fourth of July festivities for the good
of the town
even though he was feeding his people to
a monster there's also a shot of people
holding hands on a carnival ride now
judging from their awesome clothes
that's Joyce and hopper it's the shorts
guys some troops move to the lab and
then more great spielberg framing
Michael Evan and max crouched behind the
counter just like the kids in the
kitchen scene in Jurassic Park and then
Steve and her adopted son Dustin pull
out this container of god-knows-what
reminding me of ghostbusters ectoplasm
or maybe that ooze from Ninja Turtles -
maybe they found this secretly stored in
their freezers in Steve's ice cream shop
another example of how this star Court
mall could be part of an
interdimensional conspiracy next clip
I need you to trust me
okay there's another shot of that
Collider device and then Lucas and Erica
watches military helicopters swoop into
the town and then that other new
character fight firing off a few rounds
of a machine gun and later there's an
awesomely framed shot of these two
characters squaring off in front of the
portal then there's this shot of the car
as it speeds toward the mall burning
rubber and mall parking lots in 1985
yeah I see what you're referencing but I
also think this is the car that shows up
inside the mall another shot so maybe
they have to Ram the doors to get inside
Nancy wrestles with the nasty creature
and then there's a shot of Max Mike
Lucas and will with 11 and a house as
this creature has its tendrils bursting
through walls 11 holds it all back with
her powers
so in addition to the design of the
alien in the thing there's definitely
some Stephen King influence here like
the interdimensional creatures that
attacked the people in the grocery store
in the mist Kings influences obviously
all over stranger things I can see
someone I pointed out how Lucas using
the slingshot as he does here is exactly
the weapon that the losers Club of Derry
is against the monster in it moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
hereafter Maxis teen crying her older
brother Billy walks down a flickering
light hallway because I guess bulbs
never work in horror films but look
closely at his arms there looks to be
some kind of inky poison running through
his veins
in the previous trailer Billy's arm had
a similar mark on it but now it appears
to have spread all over I'm wondering if
this could be him in the process of
transforming into some kind of
Cronenberg mess it would be awesome to
see the handsomest thing on the show
turn into the ugliest then Will's neck
spidey sense returns and the kids gaze
up in fear as we hear the sounds of
fracturing glass I'm assuming the glass
ceiling of the mall is shattering here
Justin says Holy Mother of God which
seems like a nod to one of the final
lines of The Goonies which would be
appropriate since Dustin's character is
essentially a cross between chunk and
mouth from The Goonies a wide shot shows
the star court malls lights going out
but over black we hear the growl of the
Beast I gotta hand it to the sound
designers because the monster sounds so
fearsome especially with those weird
clicks it's almost like the clicks of
insects or bats
using real-life animal noises gives this
creature such a more vivid tactile
presence make it feel even more
terrifying on to the final clip
okay the kids hide in the mall in the
sounds emitted by this thing get crazier
and crazier you can hear what sounds
like a wet slither like an anaconda and
mud and then as it exhales there's kind
of like this flaps of flesh fluttering
kind of like the puff of a horse dan how
many species did this thing eat whatever
it is it must be huge because you could
see some massive form lumbering behind
the counter where max Mike and 11 are
the final episode of season 3 will be
titled the Battle of Star Court which
hopefully will be more visible with the
Battle of Winterfell and less divisive
than the Battle of King's Landing
comment down below with your favorite
moment from this trailer follow me on
instagram and twitter at EI vas and
subscribing the rockstars because in the
week following stranger things released
on July 4th will dig deep into the
details and Easter eggs from this season
thank you for watching in I cannot wait
to watch stranger things 3 like the
older sister and poltergeist watching
their house getting sucked into nothing
[Music]